on reparle de la sphère grégory une
pièce du dossier en l'occurrence la
lettre anonymes du corbeau adressés aux
parents du petit garçon
maintes fois examinés au cours des
diverses instructions pour et je dis
bien pourrait révéler un indices cachés
et qui relancerait la piste la roche
la première piste d'ailleurs dans cette
affaire et sur cette lettre apparaît une
empreinte qui n'avait pas été détectée
jusqu'à présent on y devine même des
lettres
certains pensent déjà que ce document
est très important parce qu'anne des
chats la dernière lettre du corbeau reçu
par jean marie villemin au lendemain de
la mort de grégory
c'est en examinant soigneusement que le
gendarme de niclin de la section de
recherches de metz avait repéré il ya
quatre ans une empreinte en creux sans
doute laissé par le stylo lorsqu'on a
écrit sur la feuille suivante de lettres
peut-être un est la gauche mais surtout
à droite un b majuscule elle b comme la
roche bernard
la ressemblance avec sa signature avait
à l'époque parue troublante à doni klein
qui avait transmis ces travaux à l'un
des experts nommés par le juge lambert
annulé par la suite pour une faute de
procédure
que sont ils devenus pour certains cette
empreinte prouve que bernard laroche a
eu la lettre en main pour d'autres
notamment m lombard l'avocat de la
famille laroche
il faut rester prudent et de la conclure
qu'un protagoniste pourquoi ne pas le
nommer bernard laroche a eu avec
certitude cette pièce en main il ya un
pack pour ma part je me refuse à
franchir
alors comment ce que la sphère peut être
éventuellement relancer leurs sept
places à votre avis à mon sens cette
pièce ne relancera pas la faire à elle
seule elle s'inscrira dans un nombre
d'éléments qui sont connus qui font de
ce dossier dossier extraordinaire cette
pièce ne manquera pas en tout cas de
relancer la guerre des clans partisans
de la culpabilité de christine villemin
contre partisans de celle de la roche
nous savons que le juge simon va bientôt
entendre le gendarme klein comme témoin
il ne manquera pas de lui apporter les
négatifs de ces photos
quels usages le jugement fera t-il en
attendant le mystère grégory continue